hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
I'm really excited to check out this
trailer even though I've never played
the game I want to check out the trailer
because the last trailer was [ __ ]
awesome I remember that one and I see a
lot of trailer Just Cause 3 trailer last
one was just a [ __ ] one of him just
falling down and I've seen footage of
like the I've seen friends play just
does one and two just not my that's my
just cuz I want to check this out
because I I'm starting to get a need two
summers coming around
opportunities are awakening for me
mm-hmm
I'm thinking it's about time I play some
goddamn video games instead of just
watching trailers learning so much about
the games I might play what if again
yeah I'm sorry the squirrel students the
fact that he's got a rocket launcher at
his back legs better
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
Just Cause 3 pre-order now to subscribe
coming holiday 2015 a lot it looks like
a blast I want to do all those things
there's so much carnage I want to do all
those things but in real life that would
be way more fun because you would be
successful of taking some of it he back
flipped off of a moving car driving off
the end of a ram I've seen a lot of
footage of things of people jumping off
moving cars not back flipping off of
them ie that was though in my head I'm
just seeing a montage of you tried to do
everything that the Just Cause guy does
and every single time landing on your
back wrong haha that doesn't sound like
Ryan right it sounds like ride right I
love the way everything looks it looks
so like cinematic yeah it's very easy
for these kind of games to like fall
into that like everything's like grays
and browns and just like blown up but
for there was like there was saturation
it was beautiful yeah like the whole
shot of like him like tearing through
like the field of sunflowers yeah so
good everyone loves a good shot of a guy
on a bike with a gun mm-hmm [ __ ]
shooting and the guy in the squirrel
suit falling down from the sky carrot
with an RPG strapped to his back lands
on a jet it checks the silent hops and
the jet takes over you've seen a live
free or die hard right the fourth one
yeah it looks a lot it's just like
driving cars into helicopters and like
taking on f15 jets is just like sure why
the [ __ ] not but live for your die-hard
works as a video game this looks a lot
better than that movie yeah yeah anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the real
rejects if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects it's
something you can do and you can check
out Dan's gaming channel that cyber
channel that's something you must do you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
where if we didn't have followers
product placement and we're looking to
get product placement by poker chips
poker chips are great because it makes
it a lot easier to play the game you
don't
counting the money you know and also if
you want to steal some chips from
someone you just take it hide it in your
girl's vagina and then they walk away
they're very convenient they fit in like
nobody if you fit several in their
several poker chips can fit into of a
child care how small what why would I do
it just cause